uh tell us what this is this animal this
is great this whole time it's gonna be a
water animal and look uh oh you gotta
watch out when he does that
because that's when right they're gonna
i didn't do anything i'm sitting at my
desk you're like oh watch it
but look he's gonna go fishing oh look
at that now what the [ __ ] what is he
eating there are those little minnows or
something oh those are fish
those are actually those are little
minnows i know they're
fish what's your problem they call it
they call them they're minnows you're
absolutely right and then
and what's amazing this bird is called
an ibis and ibises are found in africa
they're one of the
persons and look how adapted this guy is
for fishing i mean he's even on the side
of the tank but imagine like in a lake
he could actually use those lakes so
that would be like bigger and more fish
yeah it'd be a lot bigger fish
uh anyway yeah so he he purchased there
and he uses this long beak
he's pretty much lost interest uh and
he's crapping on my desk that's how he
says
it was hello i was like he stopped for a
second i was wondering what's he doing
now oh yeah of course
no it's so cool this bird is cool now
check out this next one coming this is
really incredible
okay we're going to leave this bird here
he looks pretty comfortable for the time
being now look what kevin has now this
is really
another let me guess what this is this
is an owl he's an owl
he's that i've been reading up i
i watched a nature show watch this he'll
perch right up in conan i'm gonna put
him right here
put him where put him on me well no no
he's got talents he'll bite or he'll
scratch you really badly oh yeah just
hold him a centimeter from my head
scratch your face off can i put him here
near your forehead i'll put him on your
leg what are you doing why are you
putting him on my crotch
he's heavy but this bird won't stop
messing all over the place
i've never been so unhappy
look at that bird is beautiful he's
looking at me do you notice how he moved
his head
yeah he's sort of like the actor in the
oc who keeps looking over his shoulder
anyone notice that
we should try and play menacing music if
we get him to look that way and then
turn around
okay cut me to a side camera now let's
get him to look over here watch this
okay touch her sideshow here we go
[Music]
yes i didn't do anything i didn't even
go near that bird
oh it's interested in the fish again
yeah he likes that so what's what's cool
is
this um the level of your information
so yeah he likes that anyway this
smaller fatter bird likes this
what kind of owl is it called the great
horned owl because he has the horns but
they're not horns they're actually
feathers that and they're not ears yeah
i could tell they weren't horns uh
and he looked amazing too how he moved
his head he actually has
twice as many neck vertebrae then than
we do so 14 of them so he can spin his
head around
the first fact and we're only 13 minutes
into the segment you want to hear him
make a sound
yeah can we hear him make a sound come
here real quick this is my assistant
kevin listen oh hey kevin kevin actually
has to here make the owl noise real
quick
oh
i like how even the owl won't look at
him right in the eye
hell's like
so who did you just brought him out to
make the noise or do you think the owl
was going to do it you know i don't know
i thought the owl might have done it
because
actually that noise that kevin made is
exactly what the great hall you need
kevin to do that noise i go
did you fly that guy in for this yeah
that's what he does okay it's remarkable
no no i'm going to come to your house
and crap all over the place
here look at this oh i don't even know
what i'm doing here oh there you go
thanks dom
oh it thought did you see that it
thought my pompadour was a bird of pride
i think he did
he thought it was a lot of animals are
afraid of this thing right here
look at that guy this guy what is this
can i pick him up what is it is it this
is a that's my beaver
here pick him up
you are such a child
i gotta go on conan and see that's my
neighbor
this is a beaver huh and i thought
beavers would they they like chew wood
and stuff don't they do they choose
hey tom grammy is log real quick now
check that look what is this the guy who
was brought in to hold a log
yeah it's amazing but when you're
touching this beaver it's something like
feel it out
look at this log would you look at this
look this is what this beaver did did
this vlog is that unbelievable wow he
took the bark right off of it yeah
but that's the way what are you gonna do
with the you just show the loggers that
does the beaver do something
i just want to show you the log it was
pretty cool but but
we could have imagined what a log looks
like we're going to log in buy the log a
seat on an airplane
but look at this uh here hold them up
like that look at this tail too
you have to show everyone this tail this
tail is unbelievable and look at this it
feels like it feels like a crusty
pancake or something isn't that
unbelievable
right touch it and what's amazing crusty
pancakes
they use this for your turns are so
fancy and complicated
the lexicon but what's neat is they're
they're actually little engineers and
beavers
can use this to do you smell them too
doesn't that smell weird
not really i don't smell anything you
don't smell that they have like this oil
all over them and this oil is what keeps
them warm but if you have it honestly
it'll stink up your hands for
for days no okay great
great great it's exciting it's gonna be
great when jessica alba's on later in
the week
but instincts yeah but honestly this if
a beaver bit you
yeah it would be they could go through a
broomstick so can you imagine what they
do to a finger it's unbelievable
worse than a broomstick worse than a
broomstick all right we gotta keep
moving we're gonna
slap this guy okay let's move this along
and uh okay thanks tom
okay what's next oh my god all right
here we go here we go here we go
look at this guy now this is another
awesome water animal this is this is a
crocodile
but it's are you just realizing that or
well
this is this is a crocodile look at him
hold on whoa whoa whoa do you have
control of this thing it's not he will
bite your finger off
look at those chompers check this out
now check what out what do you think
make sure you got a hold on here
i got a good hold this oh great i hold
the wiener that's right
but what i wanted to demonstrate
see see you were ready to put your
you're ready to play you're ready you're
ready to put your finger in its mouth
okay ready i am so disappointed in
everybody tonight all right
oh look at that are you sure i'm okay
yeah go ahead
okay now look at that look at the end of
that can you imagine that was your
finger that would be
unbelievable i was imagining something
else but all right
it's my foot
people sicken
[Applause]
i have a brother that does that just
takes a big bite and just let sits there
for a while
my saliva will dissolve it oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
still not eating it it's just sitting
there no cuz how does this
how does this animal survive in the wild
stuff and that you gotta chew dude but
okay now again nile crocodile the jaws
believe it if this was a finger it could
definitely and they have about 100
pounds of pressure in their jaws right
now